[Music]
there's something about being part of
nature there's something about being
around these animals even the most
wounded veteran they feel different he's
been part of something greater than
themselves the idea is that you've got
to give someone who's been through a
severe trauma an opportunity to heal and
we believe it warriors and wolves
program and a back to nature setting it
does that we have 40 animals at this
facility there you go you got we've
rescued wolves off the chains in Alaska
as part of a roadside attraction we
rescued wolf dogs for a backyard breeder
in San Diego I think for all the
veterans that we bring out here whether
they work here or they're here first the
fourth group what rings true is if they
could heal I can use the Wolves the null
if you're injured or for the solemn view
and they have the trauma and you know we
had some type of trauma on life we can
get that connection and one won't be
your friend for life what happens is one
animal picks that one veteran never
again does that animal pick someone else
never again does that animal want to
show the same kind of affection to
someone else what a good boy
conventional therapy isn't really
something for me didn't help to be
honest after ten years of military life
it was sort of a tough transition and I
continued down my course of being angry
drinking myself to death may have been
last chapter of my life
[Music]
there are things I've seen that I can't
unsee there are things I've done that I
cannot undo you're saying that well I
get it
in the name of my country doesn't help
you sleep in that but what does help you
sleep is having a companion they kind of
teach you how to be calm and confident
it's got some deeper meaning when they
accept you they accept you into the
salmon part of the pack
[Music]
you